Sara Lance aka white canary is a
relentless positive force who faces up
to her inner demons overcomes them and
now helps others with theirs let's
follow the many twists and turns of Sara
Lance's life through time and space
heaven and hell and all points in
between
Sara the daughter of Starling city
police captain Quentin Lance is a rebel
she meets her match and bad boy Oliver
Queen and pursues him despite her sister
Laurel being his official girlfriend
Oliver invites Sara aboard the ill-fated
yacht the Queen's Gambit and she accepts
after a huge fight with her sister of
course she doesn't know that the yacht
has been sabotaged by the sinister
Malcolm Merlyn and she is swept out to
sea presumed dead her disappearance
sends a shock wave through the Lance
family Quentin turns to drinking and
drifts apart from his wife Dinah Laurel
is conflicted because her boyfriend has
been cheating on her with Sara and she
can't reconcile her grief and anger
Dinah refuses to believe sara is dead
and alienates her family with this
belief Sara survives the explosion on
the Queen's Gambit and is rescued by the
crew of the ship the Amazo
she is conscripted by doctor Anthony Ivo
to assist him in his experiments while
he searches for mirakuru a serum that
enhances strength healing and quickness
faced with a decision to either help the
twisted dr. Ivo and his torturous
experiments or being made into a test
subject herself Sara chooses survival
Oliver who's been stranded on an island
is also rescued by the ship and he's as
surprised to see Sara as she is to see
him they eventually team up to betray
Ivo and return to Oliver's Island prison
of Lian Yu
when the Amazo sinks in a fight Oliver
thinks sara has been killed yet again I
saw you die not the first time that's
happened right but she survives and when
she washes up on shore she can't find
Oliver she's discovered by Nyssa al Ghul
who nurses her back to health and helps
train her as a member of the League of
Assassins Sara and miss abhi come lovers
during the several years worth of
training Sara receives to become a
killer
sara is drawn back to Starling city to
make good on a promise to protect the
troubled young woman named sin of course
the League of Assassins isn't the kind
of organization you can get a permission
slip to leave once you remember you're a
member for life dressed in a black mask
and using a sonic device Sara beats up a
bunch of bad guys and runs afoul of the
doll maker who kidnaps her family Sara
kills the doll maker against Oliver's
wishes but nonetheless Oliver and Sara
reconnect and rekindle their romance
unfortunately sara has a problem the
league wants her back after a series of
assassination attempts and failed
kidnappings Nyssa finally relents after
Sara tries to poison herself Sara joins
team arrow reconnects with her father
and continues her relationship with
Oliver after a while the intensity of
Oliver's vengeance driven mission starts
the where Sara down she decides to leave
town for a bit but pops back in again
just in time to help defeat Slade Wilson
aka Deathstroke once and for all after
rejoining Nyssa and the league for a
while she returns to Starling city once
again to confirm rumors of Malcolm
merlyn's return only to get riddled with
arrows shot by all of her sister Thea
queen who's being mind-controlled by
Malcolm this time around death looks
like it's going to be a lot more
permanent but a grief-stricken Laurel
and Thea have other plans they demand
that Merlyn now head of the league
resurrect Sara using the life-restoring
waters of the Lazarus Pit of course the
problem with the pit is that it restores
life to someone's body but doesn't
restore their soul supernatural expert
John Constantine is called in to bring
her soul back sara is finally whole
again
thank you John oh you wanna believe I
owed you one mate Sara stays around for
a while in the now renamed star City but
she is haunted by the lingering
bloodthirstiness brought on by her
Lazarus Pit experienced on the plus side
Laurel finally makes up with Sara since
she is now fighting crime as the Black
Canary
Laurel dubs her little sister the white
canary be hero in the light
be the white canary but she goes back to
Nyssa her old lover tells her that she
needs to find her own path that path
opens up when rip hunter captain of the
time and space traveling ship the
Waverider offers her a chance to save
the world from Vandal Savage rip has his
own agenda of course and the reason he
picks this particular group of misfits
is that if they're removed from the
timeline they aren't going to be missed
it can make them sacrificial pawns in
his desperate attempt to save his family
from being killed by Vandal Savage at
one point Sara gets time stranded in
1958 so she makes her way back to the
League of Assassins yet again by the
time rescue comes
she's firmly a part of the league again
and has forgotten her past just as she's
going to kill one of her former friends
she recalls her true place in the
legends torn between the league and the
legends guild master Ra's al Ghul makes
the decision for her he releases her
though she's a killer she wants to show
mercy too much to be a real assassin oh
so mr. violent by your ability to kill
and your desire to show mercy the team
eventually learns that their every
action is foreseen and manipulated by
the time masters rip hunters former
bosses in a desperate attempt to escape
the time masters clutches Sara helps
blow up the device that manipulates them
when she returns to Star City in the
present day her father tells her that
Laurel has died
Sara's grief stricken by her loss but
ripped finally reveals that if he hadn't
plucked her out of time when he did Sara
would have died too
after reforming the team the legends of
tomorrow kill off savage simultaneously
in three different time periods with
Sara snapping his neck in 1975 after the
team's successes Sara decides to stay
with the legends to fulfill laurels
dream of her becoming a hero in the
light in the middle of season two of
legends of tomorrow the earth is invaded
by an alien species called the
dominators this kicks off the first
major crossover between arrow the flash
legends and Supergirl Sara gets to meet
Supergirl for the first time but they
don't have much time to get to know each
other
Sara and a few of
our mind controlled by the aliens to
attack the flash and the arrow later
sara is teleport is inside the Dominator
ship and becomes part of a dream
scenario with Oliver and some of the
other heroes it's an insidious plan
because it gives them all a fantasy of
living a normal life apart from super
heroics you're looking at a trained
assassin or anything after the heroes
combined forces save the day
Oliver and Sara share a moment with
Oliver saying that in retrospect the
dominators gave them a gift the back
half of season two of the legends of
tomorrow sees the team chasing after the
spear of destiny while battling against
the Legion of Doom which includes
Malcolm Merlyn damian darhk-- and eobard
thawne who all want the spear for their
own purposes at one point Merlyn
captures Sara and makes her an offer
that's hard to refuse in exchange for
her giving him an amulet that helps him
find the spear he'll change the timeline
and never interfere with the Queen's
Gambit Sara will have the chance to live
a normal life and Laurel will still be
alive Sara refuses No thank you I was
never meant for those things and I know
that later a mind-control drip shoot
Sara in the stomach nearly bringing
about a fourth death for the white
canary which well just keep watching
luckily she gets better eventually the
Legion gets the spear and changes
reality dark turned Sara into his
personal assassin but the rest of the
legend snap her back by way of a memory
gun Sara eventually wields the spear as
given one last temptation a movie night
with Laurel even knowing that it isn't
real she is still tempted to undo
everything that is damaged her Laurel
tells her everything led her to this
moment and the spear needs someone to
help protect reality Sara returns
reality to normal deep hours the spear
and the villains are defeated the only
problem with this happy ending is that
as a result of using the spear the
legends inadvertently break time rip
hunter forms a new organization the time
Bureau and officially disbands the
legends feeling that they only tend to
make things worse Sara is reduced to
working a boring retail job in Star City
until Mick
Rory calls her up after finding Julius
Caesar on a beach they get the legends
back together steal the Waverider from
the time bureau and start fixing time
anachronism z' Sarah's new frenemy is
Ava sharp Rip's top time Bureau agent
and they're arguing reveals a simmering
mutual attraction Sarah discovers that a
demon named malice is trying to manifest
in this reality and that he can only be
stopped by accruing magical totems Sarah
is temporarily possessed by a death
totem but overcomes its influence Sarah
and Ava break up but get back together
after they both learned that Ava is a
clone from the future by the end of the
season malice is able to manifest and
seems like he's going to wreak havoc in
this reality the legends combine their
powers through the amulets to create a
creature of light a giant fuzzy toy
named Bebo Bebo wads
bebo takes malice high up into the air
and flattens him creating a blue
heart-shaped mushroom cloud sarah and
the gang take time out for the wedding
of Barry Allen and iris West Sarah meets
Alex Danvers Kara Supergirl Danvers
sister and it's lust at first sight but
to get drunk and fool around although
Sarah is clearly a bit more cavalier
about the hook-up than Alex's how are
you do I'm good lil hung over but I'll
survive how you touch me but like many
superhero weddings this one is crashed
by uninvited guests in this case Nazi
soldiers led by dark arrow / girl and
Prometheus Sarah and Alex team up to
defeat Prometheus who is Tommy Merlyn of
Earth X and earth we're Nazis won World
War two and continued to rule after a
big battle that the good guys lose
everyone is brought to earth X and taken
prisoner there Sarah meets the earth X
version of her dead Quentin who reveals
that he killed the Earth X version of
Sarah after finding out that she was
bisexual
I hate fire luckily Sarah and the gang
get rescued by Leo snart the gay earth
ex doppelganger of captain cold who is
also a leader of the freedom fighters
they team up in order to return to Earth
one and a huge battle ensues where our
heroes win the day
unfortunately Martin Stein dies in the
crossover the team attends his funeral
before moving on as Alex and Sarah both
say their goodbyes get that shut up the
fourth season of legends of tomorrow
sees the team dealing with yet another
mistake in letting malice emerge all
sorts of other magical creatures also
came through at various points in time
the big bad this time is near on a lord
of Hell who has it out for John
Constantine while dealing with monsters
and the mysterious masked nations of a
government conspiracy Constantine alters
time to rescue an old lover the result
is a series of disastrous timeline
crashes were Sarah Ava and Gideon become
these sirens of space-time and all of
the male legends get killed off another
timeline see Sarah and the gang get
turned into the puppets of tomorrow and
they have a song for every occasion
Constantine eventually does the right
thing and restores the timeline Sarah
and Ava get serious this season though
they have their ups and downs as they
try to figure out how to make each other
happy when Constantine turns them into
kids to help solve a case at a summer
camp it brings them closer eventually
the team manages to beat me Iran after
rescuing Ray Palmer from hell but the
new boss of hell and the end of reality
as we know it
both loom everything comes to a head for
Sarah Lance in the epic crisis on
Infinite Earths crossover Sarah is front
and center in the initial defense of
Earth 38 but the true revelation is that
she's one of the prophesied Paragons who
can help defeat the anti-monitor Sarah
is the paragon of Destiny as she proves
again and again her willingness to
accept her role and her fate against all
temptation reuniting with Oliver one
last time
she and the other Paragons the wart the
anti-monitor at the dawn of time when
the multiverse is recreated by the
spectre Sara is one of just six beings
to survive the old one with her memories
wholly intact the team fights the Andi
monitor one last time on the new earth
Prime
Sara brings Mia smoke from the future to
her father Oliver's funeral after
fighting at her side during the crisis
she wants to let Mia have a chance to
meet her mother Felicity and to say
goodbye to the father she never had the
chance to grow up with in season five of
legends of tomorrow
the legends face off against encores
history's greatest villains unleashed on
earth by Astra loke a woman with a
vendetta against John Constantine
however it turns out that Astra was
manipulated by atropos and Lachesis two
of the fates from Greek mythology in
another twist one of the legends Charlie
reveals that she's actually close though
the youngest fate millennia earlier she
did the fates loom because she wanted to
give humanity free will as the legends
in the fates raced to reclaim the pieces
of the loom
Sara battles the Tropos on the set of
CW's supernatural atropos revealed her
true form to Sara which should have
killed her but instead just blinds her
and give Sara the ability to see the
future deaths of any person she touches
knowing that Charlie is the best one to
use the loom of fate the legends fight
off a zombie horde for as long as they
can
sarah gets overrun by zombies and dies
again but this gives Charlie enough time
to escape and rewrite time atropos and
Lachesis rewrite reality so that people
are slaves to the fates but Charlie
saves the legends by splitting them up
and placing them in TV shows what kind
of drama lens are you the legends
breakout and Sara kills a Tropos but
while celebrating their victory at a
punk show Sara is kidnapped by aliens
setting up next season's big conflict
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite superheroes are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]
you